[Musique]
George Herbert Walker Bush était le
dernier grand homme d'État soldat américain un
père fondateur du XXe siècle à servir il
devait réussir à présider il devait l'emporter
[Musique]
cette initiative historique de
réunification allemande n'aurait jamais pu
réussir sans le brillant
leadership du président  Bush, je crois
qu'on dira qu'aucun occupant du
bureau ovale n'était plus courageux, plus respectueux des
principes et plus honorable que
George Herbert Walker Bush.
avait le ministre en vie, je l'ai appelé, j'ai dit
papa, je t'aime et tu as été un
père merveilleux
et les derniers mots qu'il dirait jamais sur
terre étaient je t'aime aussi
le meilleur père qu'un fils ou une fille puisse
avoir et dans notre chagrin, mais un  souris en
sachant que papa serre Robin dans ses bras et
tient à nouveau la main de maman
[Musique]